a deadline has come and gone for allies
of former president trump to hand over
documents to the january 6th select
house committee the next step now could
be a fight over executive privilege
another committee report reveals how far
the president former president that is
was willing to go to try to overturn the
2020 election results nicole killian is
on capitol hill for us once again nicole
good morning hey good morning to you
tony and in addition to these documents
the select committee wants these former
trump aides to appear for depositions
next week a spokesperson for the former
president tells cbs news the committee's
request is outrageously broad and lacks
precedent and merit
they are some of the highest ranking
trump administration officials targeted
by the house select committee
investigating the january sixth attack
on the u.s capitol a letter reviewed by
cbs news from former president trump's
legal team instructs those who were
subpoenaed not to cooperate in producing
documents or testimony it cites
executive and other privileges and
argues president trump is prepared to
defend these fundamental privileges in
court the current occupant of the white
house gets to make the decision on
executive privilege so i would remind
the former president that he is not the
current president and so he doesn't
have that right democratic vice chair
pete aguilar is a member of the select
committee and says criminal referrals
are possible do you see that as the next
step it's definitely an option that the
committee has we'll look at whatever
mechanisms we have including the
criminal
piece the developments follow the
release of a senate judiciary report
thursday that found mr trump went to
great lengths to pressure the department
of justice to undo the 2020 election we
were barely a half step away for a
full-blown constitutional crisis the
democratic-led investigation revealed
then president trump demanded doj reject
the election results at least nine times
between the election and january 6. one
white house attorney likened his efforts
to a murder-suicide pact when he
contemplated ousting his acting attorney
general during an oval office meeting
january third the president rejected it
the president did the right thing
iowa senator chuck grassley who is up
for re-election next year is set to
appear with the former president at a
save america rally on saturday meantime
the select committee has announced three
new subpoenas for organizers of the stop
the steel rally on january 6. the
committee hopes to produce a report
sometime next year gail
all right nicole thank you very much